Speaker 1: Now, if you want an example of
just how bad this is now getting in terms of
consuming medical resources, there are now three
emergency rooms that have had to close in Texas
because there's just too much covid Memorial
Hermann closes three standalone emergency
rooms in Greater Houston. Covid-19 Surge Prompts
Resource Management for hospital system. Memorial
Hermann announced Monday that due to the continued
covid-19 surge and the strain on the hospital
system's operation, it was closing three of its
24 hour emergency rooms as a five p.m. Monday
until further notice. The three are in Kingwood
Spring and CNN Texas statement from the media
relations team says patients who are currently
receiving care inside any of these emergency
rooms will be safely discharged or transferred to
another Memorial Hermann facility. Members of our
community who require emergent care should proceed
to another nearby emergency center for assistance.
Closing these locations allows us to reassign
the staff to other locations where their help
is critically needed. It also eliminates the need
to transfer these patients to the main hospital
for admission if necessary. So what's happening is
that overall the strain is so huge that they need
to close these centers to send people elsewhere
to deal with the covid surge. And this is exactly
the point we've been talking about now for several
weeks. We had a video during a live stream from a
doctor in Louisiana who commented about this very
eloquently. This affects everyone who might need
an E.R. if you drive your car. You could get into
an accident if a kid goes to school or camp where
they could get hurt, they might not have access to
an emergency room. These three emergency rooms are
now closed period to everybody because the staff
need to go elsewhere to deal with covid patients,
most of whom are unvaccinated. So this is not
hypothetical. These are now three emergency rooms
not available. The vaccine is free. Remember, the
vaccine is free. Texas has been crazy lately. You
had there go it alone libertarian electrical grid,
which left them without power when the storms hit.
Then they had a heat wave causing such a
demand on electricity that they started
restricting people's power availability,
turning down people, smart thermostats,
and now they have emergency room rooms close and
closing. And there's a real good chance that this
this gets even worse in November, December and
January. Hopefully we're seeing a leveling off
of the Delta variant wave. It's not clear yet. We
may be. We may not be. The growth rate is slowing,
but we're about to head into flu
season and it's at least suspected
that there's a flu like seasonality to covid
still to be seen if it happens again this year.
It happened last year. A situation was different.
We didn't yet have vaccines out. Now we do.
And this is once again raising that question
that we talked about in the last segment.
Should unvaccinated people be prioritized
in some way, not ignored, not denied care,
but should vaccination status by choice,
exempting those who can't get the vaccine
because of some specific condition? Should
vaccination status be considered in terms of
triage? We're going to continue talking about
exactly that question on our Instagram. Make
sure you're following us there at David Pakman
show. We'll take a quick break and be right back